and this time you know where it needs
will you do it all again where's that
good man now
should you play dishonored too with no
powers on very hard with Bethesda
announcing New Game+ maybe you'll want
to replay the campaign a little
differently so let's find out if no
power is on very hard is worth your time
first off it doesn't take long to
realize it's very hard especially with
the clean slate with no upgrades and
skills thank God for quick safe because
when you're up against three or more
guards you'll find yourself overwhelmed
and dead
despite this sequels attempt to push you
to play through the burn of losing that
element of surprise on very hard with no
powers it's a different story playing
like this practically forces you to
sneak turning you into that stealth
perfectionist there's no room for sloppy
kills with witnesses which makes taking
the non-lethal route that much more
difficult because choking out someone
puts you in the spotlight for longer in
sticky situations it's easier to stealth
kill and get rid of the evidence later
and with no powers you're very much
reliant on your environment using
bottles for distractions are vital when
you hit that roadblock of guards tossing
one can generally refresh the situation
allowing you to pick them off one by one
obviously this is a stealth game and
you're probably already doing this yet
what's a notable change was being forced
to climb and traverse without powers
oftentimes this was the most frustrating
part of the game I found myself
constantly questioning whether or not I
could grab a Ledge or if I was even
supposed to shimmy around the side of
the building climbing back up on a box
to a balcony shouldn't be this hard yet
there's a slight overhang off the wall
that stopped me from jumping in these
moments that made me really wish I had
blink or far reach especially when
considering how heavily the game rewards
exploration with bone charms and runes
even choosing that high ground
roundabout around open areas feels
essential yet too often I questioned if
my parkour routes were legitimate or
broken however over time you learn or at
least forgive traversal frustrations and
at this point I was ready to try the
next step towards insanity no HUD slowly
removing objective icons made me realize
how stuffy the air was taking off health
meters with it whew and we're not
sweating in here and then the awareness
markers Wow can't really breathe this is
weird here we go let's check out the
journal says find a map alright let's do
this guards already spot me great but
how did I know that the audio chimes
whenever you're spotted the game cues
varied audio swells that reflect to what
degree you've been seen say a guard
catches a brief glimpse of you it's this
and then when you're straight-up caught
and this is really all you need having
to rely on audio this much keeps the
tension high and puts you on your toes
searching without an objective marker
seems like a waste of time but if
there's one thing Dishonored 2 nails is
its environments removing the marker
remove the hand-holding and made the map
incredibly more mysterious because
you're forced to look at every piece of
scrap paper you're unraveling side
narratives that you may have missed
before even when you are lost or stuck
at a locked door corvo's raspy inner
dialogue kicks in to remind you he might
be an i patient's office to which you
can check a map on the stairwell and
easily find out what floor you're on yet
there will be times where you need to
turn it on like when you're operating
chemistry equipment something's missing
that no one has time for this all in all
it's been quite the experience if you're
looking to replay the campaign it's
worth a shot playing without powers
might not be for you but I do recommend
removing some of that HUD as smudge it
brings out an all-around insanely
immersive experience if you have any
pointers or comments please put them in
the comment section below or feel free
to send them my way on Twitter thanks
for watching